welcome to this video of super Mouse
again let's see if I do better now I get
this weird would Indian counter position
in the game before okay I'm preventing
Bishop f5 this time it's a okay that
looks very Kings Indian style okay what
is he doing with a 6b five maybe that's
a possibility No okay so can I go g3 or
not let's play it first and then think
about the consequences b6 Wow
and ok let's reroute night h4 also was a
move to be considered but i just wanted
to kick him back down from age 5 the
question is I mean I'm not probably i'm
not really threatening to take h5
because of 93
yeah that's the kind of move yeah you
know it's not working in some way but
you still have to refute it ok I'm going
to take probably bishop tanks ok g-form
g4 now or when exactly should I play it
but if not f 46 I'm it should really
work
no i don't i don't really see how is how
is swindling me here not a for maybe
it's always tricky because you don't
have a very clear idea where the king is
going yeah okay so i'm going to check
first here and then f5 somewhere where
is the king going Bishop g4 3611
possibility long castles always also
runs into into stuff on the on the C
file it looks good right this check
sorry this one check there's a check on
the rook king can go to f1 chennai def
three with with tempo on the rook bishop
wanted to go to e6 but okay that's not
but I have Knight f3 next it's that
still reasonably solid when the King on
g2 is not getting checkmated so easily
Knight f6 I am sorry Knight f3 I guess
rook g1 maybe on is Queen f5 coming gfs
or g5
I've been okay if he goes g5g one is
still possible doing this attacking the
Jeep on cannot be bad I'm preparing rook
rook g1 also
yeah objectively wide winsome but it's
and still [ __ ] her she okay b5 had so
thats that looks really slow so i'm
going to rock g6 okay 95 I hope but I'm
not overlook land think I know I don't
ok I'm glad that I could refute that
yeah it's often I mean you you really
have those games in the Kings Indian
where something is going terribly wrong
for black like it did here yeah
something is I mean terribly wrong it's
a bit much he could play a normal move
now but where something wrong happens
and they just play something that lashes
out and it's not working objectively but
you still have to refute it so teak said
he tried to make that work but I don't
think it did it is working cheeks jinx
okay maybe I'm this wasn't something
check it wasn't really helping much but
it didn't it didn't hurt okay as long as
the comm group g1 winsome okay the
compasses sees nothing in particular so
I probably was was was okay then yeah
what a thought is actually here um that
he has maybe the opportunity to play
yeah to let's say a five I know I be
Ricans be 5 and so on but the idea is
that taking us probably not such a great
idea no not sure about this position how
good it is especially in a blitz game I
probably would have after a five and I
would have I'm sorry after a five I
would have considered slower
continuations maybe a three or something
something along along these lines
it's very hits a complicated complicated
scenario tough to say wow okay thanks
for watching